thank you for joining us
Jordans with us in Iowa hi Jordan how
are you hi David how are you
better than I deserve how can I help
thanks for taking my call I'm in a bit
of a dilemma I have a degree in business
marketing I came out Jeffrey's College
which is a blessing my husband we put
him through law school so you can
imagine that was a lot of student debt
loan so my question is what it'd be
silly for me to go back to school for
nursing which I've always wanted to do
when I can contribute now with my degree
in business have you gotten a husband
student loans paid off no how much are
they 175,000 oh and your household
incomes what 60,000 your household
income is 60,000 and he's an attorney
yeah just started okay and what do you
make I'm saying home mom and so that's
kind of what my dilemma is is you know
we're now we just started your whole
program and so we are starting Ron
they've step two obviously with the
student debt loan but now I'm kind of
deciding you know now that we talked
about me going back to school or getting
a job the job was obviously the first
conversation and then I decided maybe
I'll go back to school because I really
have always wanted to do nursing but
that just now kind of seems silly when
we are gonna be in baby step two for
that long mm-hmm were you in the
workplace before nope I out of college
we had got married and had our kids and
so I've just been staying at home no
Claire's been while he was in school
Yeah right and you have a degree in
marketing and business mm-hmm yeah so
really your goal was to stay at home
well we got pregnant in college so you
know I I'm not saying it's a bad thing
I'm just saying you have done what you
wanted to do which you
wanted to be do we stay home and the
only reason this discussion is coming
along his money yes yeah so in other
words let's say his student loans were
all paid off and he was making $150,000
a year
you wouldn't been there she would be at
home well I think I would go back to
school at that point so I think that's
one goal you're going you're goal is not
to be at home if he was making a ton of
money you wouldn't be at home I think I
would want to be a nurse you can work
you know part-time or full-time and I do
like getting out of the house so I feel
like I would still want to do that it's
interesting that that has come up now
and not a year ago I know it's it's been
crazy you know I probably would tap the
brakes on that if you're gonna go into
the marketplace right now I would just
go get you a good marketing position
making 40 50 thousand or whatever you
can make doing that and then let's get
his income up as fast as possible and
clean up his mess and then once that is
cleaned up and the kids are a little bit
older and you can cash flow and pay cash
for nursing school that's probably
that's the thing as I can cash flow
nursing school and so it's just debating
whether or not I want to cash flow or
extra money seventy-five thousand
dollars in student loan debt
yes so the money you're spending on
nursing school is not going to that
exactly
out of sixty thousand dollar household
income so not only are you not bringing
in an income you're taking some of the
income that would have been going
towards the debt so this is a double
negative okay so that for now I mean I
don't mind you can do whatever you want
to do but you're just you're you're
you're piling on it since you're
creating a bigger problem mathematically
than solving any problems that's what
I'm trying to figure out I think yeah
because you're I don't want to create
more time you're spending money and not
making money yeah that's what I mean by
double negative it's a it's a tube
one two right and so and again I'm not
saying never go back and be a nurse I'm
saying we should get some headway
towards this get his income doubled and
get your income to 50 and then we can
clean this 175 up over the next couple
three four years then go get your
nursing with cash flow once you're
debt-free and then then that puts you in
a position to do that so if you're
willing to go into the marketplace
meaning go get a job that's probably the
direction I would go and if you're
willing to go get your nursing degree
today and be away from the kids then
you're willing to go get a job so and
that's what I would do in in in this
situation again it's it's a temporary
move to clean up the mess because you've
got a big mess there